yeah he is looking happy isn't he but uh  okay the rook comes now to challenge the  black queen okay but the black rook like  you say is going to slide itself across  yup the black fruit can block this  threat to the black queen  i don't think you want to retreat with  her right now white's rooks are just too  strong you need to trade one of them off  and uh that must have been dude's idea  with his last move that black rook lift  i think i think uh hikaru is just i  think he knows he could have put much  more pressure on  wow  okay dude  take some takes upon him with his rook  but this looks like a big blunder and he  realized immediately he saw it on his  face now white can simply take that with  his queen and black after taking the  rook would actually lose a piece so dude  he just resigns it ended so suddenly in  nakamura super happy with that win yeah  that means it's over for these two as  well hikaru nakamura wins the final  match and  secures his